-Performing "Halfway to Hell,"
from his current album,
"Whitsitt Chapel,"
please welcome Jelly Roll!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I'm a county jail revival ♪
♪ I'm a bottle and a Bible ♪
♪ I'm a rolling stone disciple
with a cross across my face ♪
♪ I'm a trailer park tornado ♪
♪ Jagged edges on my halo ♪
♪ Hope the chariot gon'
swing low and carry me away ♪
♪ This little light of mine ♪
♪ Damn near burned me alive ♪
♪ Lord knows that Mama tried ♪
♪ And I don't know if I'm ♪
♪ Halfway to Heaven
or halfway to Hell ♪
♪ My angels, my demons
are at war with myself ♪
♪ One foot in the fire,
and I still can't tell ♪
♪ Am I halfway to Heaven ♪
♪ I'm halfway
to Heaven or Hell ♪
♪ I'm a dive bar Sunday sermon ♪
♪ Holy water with my bourbon ♪
♪ Standin' on a bridge
I'm burnin' ♪
♪ With a can of gasoline ♪
♪ Am I worth savin'
if I'm always fadin'? ♪
♪ It feels like
I'm caught in between ♪
Let's go!
♪ Halfway to Heaven
or halfway to Hell ♪
♪ My angels, my demons
are at war with myself ♪
♪ One foot in the fire,
and I still can't tell ♪
♪ Am I halfway to Heaven ♪
♪ I'm halfway
to Heaven or Hell ♪
♪ Man, I'm halfway to Hell ♪
♪ I'm halfway to Hell ♪
♪♪
♪ This little light of mine ♪
♪ Damn near burned me alive ♪
♪ Lord knows that Mama tried ♪
♪ And I don't know if I'm ♪
♪ Halfway to Heaven
or halfway to Hell ♪
♪ My angels and my demons
are at war with myself ♪
♪ I'm halfway to Heaven
and halfway to Hell ♪
♪ My angels, my demons
are at war with myself ♪
♪ One foot in the fire,
and I still can't tell ♪
♪ Am I halfway to Heaven ♪
♪ I'm halfway
to Heaven and Hell ♪
♪ Man, I'm halfway to Hell ♪
♪ I said I'm halfway
to Heaven and Hell ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]